le karaté c'est la discipline du corps
et de l'esprit il y a le côté mental il
y a le côté physique ce qui n'existe pas
dans tous les sports donc c'est surtout
ça qui me plaît dans le karaté et qui
qui me donne goût à transmettre mon
savoir aux personnes qui sont qui sont
volontaires pour apprendre cette art on
avance mai et on
revienti
et vous faites travailler beaucoup votre
mental
caraté contrairement à C sport cette
méthode de combat pardon le cararaté
demande une grande technicité rien n'est
fait au hasard tout est calculé donc
vous faites
travailler vous ne faites pas travailler
que vos mux vous faites beaucoup
travailler votre tête dans c'est un
exercice psychique très important tout
aussi important que l'exercice physique
le karaté c'est la discipline du corps
et de l'esprit il y a beaucoup de le
caré permet à quel un pratiquant de
méditer sur bien des choses et et en
même temps de travailler son physique et
d'apprendre à se défendre un karatk
quelqu'un qui vient ici au départ qui ne
connaissait rien dans les techniques de
combat peut être en mesure de se
défendre face à un adversaire bien plus
grand et plus Baré que lui le maître
finine je crois disait que le karaté
n'est pas fait pour servir ça veut dire
que vous n'utilisez le karaté qu'en cas
d'extrême urgence vraiment pour vous
défendre pas pour all attaquer les gens
parce qu'on est en forme c'est dire que
tout vous a permis ça d'ailleurs vous
savez plusi par la loi je rappelle quand
même que un karatéka un boxeur
professionnel ses deux pieds et ses deux
mains sont considérés comme des armes
notamment quand il est gradé à partir de
la ceinture ceinture marron ceinture
noir et cetera le gars ne peut pas se
permettre de faire n'importe quoi il
sera très sévèrement puni par la loi
pénale merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
monieur